We're not in the best shape.
Tennis, I sprained my ankle.
It's my arm.
Cigarette.
In the early times, people have had aches and pains and injuries and all sorts of things.
In the past, we didn't know how to be cured and the people lived much shorter time to take prehistory.
I got a pain up here and I can't make it stop.
What can I do?
Well, that's the magic man. He always knows what to do, sorcerer.
Ah, what is it? I'm coming. What do you want?
Okay, then I'll stop. Still hurt.
I'm in trouble with the cephalus.
What?
The cephalus?
You got a headache.
Thanks, I already knew that!
Can you cure it?
Oh sure, see lots of these.
Huh?
Oh, what are you gonna do?
Don't worry!
Nothing to worry about.
Little haircut.
And then?
Guess where it hurts?
Get it out!
How will you do it?
Little hole!
Is that a good idea?
Who's the witch doctor here?
Well, I guess you are.
And it's doctor's orders.
Still in pain?
Uh huh.
You made the hole!
Medicine was way back then.
Only sometimes.
If you think you're well, it makes you well.
Are you still in pain?
It has always had some magic to it.
In China, acupuncture was devised.
That's a treatment by sticking little needles in the skin.
In Babylon, they would consult the stars.
In Egypt, the doctors were the priests.
A scientific approach to medicine saw its origins in ancient Greece.
Its most illustrious representative would be Hippocrates.
He founded a hospital and medical school on the island of Koz.
He was the first one to use clinical observation.
observe one two three four five now we must listen to his heart place your ear upon his chest and you
will hear a sound like a pouch of leather opening and closing try to something like a wheeze yeah
the phlegm is filling his lungs now this patient should stay warm until he responds in urns of hot
water good morning hippocrates uh trouble with your arm well the other day i was lifting a boulder
I see. Well, you call that a dislocation. You come over here.
Sit down.
I must tell you, this is going to hurt, but then you'll feel better.
The arm and shoulder are out of place. It's not serious in itself, but it shouldn't be neglected.
It should be put in place. There we are.
Observe when the face is yellow and the liver is hard.
The stomachache is really gastritis.
Tell me, what have you been eating lately?
Oh, let me see. On the day of the Olympic Games, one piglet...
A whole one?
A small one.
Next day it was Salonica sausages, a knuckle of veal at night, then yesterday it was grilled squid, quite partial to squid.
I understand. The body is composed of blood, a phlegm, yellow and black bile.
A man is healthy if these elements are held in just the right balance.
And these elements are the equivalent of the four components of the universe, earth, water, air, and fire.
You ate too much, your humors are out of balance.
I can cure you, but you have to follow my orders.
First, we'll purge you.
Drink this mixture of water, honey, and vinegar for three days.
Take only light broth.
Thus, your body will not be dehydrated or overloaded.
Now, I'm going to let some blood eliminate.
My children, you have chosen to learn medicine, the most noble of all professions.
Now, I want each of you to take an oath.
Ariston, I swear by Apollo to the limit of my strength and capacity,
I will fulfill the following duty.
I will care for the sick to their advantage according to my judgment, and abstain from any harm or injustice.
Whatever a patient may reveal will be kept in confidence.
I will exercise my art in all innocence and purity, whatever house I may enter.
How's that?
Right down to our own day, 25 centuries later, all doctors take the Hippocratic Oath.
Modern science has, of course, advanced medicine beyond all recognition.
But Hippocrates' great principles are just as valid for doctors today.
And then, children, how are you feeling now?
Any of you needing a little attention?
No, no, I'm able to move my arm.
It's all gone.
Cold is cleared up.
Can run like a hare now.
And you?
What about a purge, all right?
Oh, no, no, no, no, I'm just fine.
But I wouldn't mind a little snack.
Fever hasn't gone down.
This has no effect, Marcus Aurelius.
We no longer know how to cue you, oh, Emperor.
Bunch of incompetence.
Go on, find me another doctor.
I've heard the praises of a doctor who's from Pergam. His name is Galeon.
He's no good.
I've heard all that he's good for. He's patching up gladiators.
Yet I'm told he has a great talent.
Bring him here.
Well, Galeon, aren't you taking my pulse?
Not necessary. I know what you have and what you need to get well.
He's a quack.
Right, Galeon, tell us.
You have simply eaten too much and chosen badly.
To an ordinary man, I'd say, drink a combination of wine and pepper.
But you are an emperor.
Yes, sir.
So I shall put a plaster on your stomach.
It will give you some relief.
Come back to see us tomorrow.
Marcus, bring me some wine and pepper, as he said.
Greetings, Galion. Excellent remedy.
I'm quite myself again. Good work.
I was pretty sure my plaster would do a good job.
Especially if, as I suspect, Emperor,
you added a dose of wine and pepper.
Galion would become rich and famous.
In his studies, he discovered the nervous system and the brain, which he thought was the seat of the soul.
He thought it was in the liver that food was transformed into blood.
The many papers that he was to write on medicine were references for over a thousand years.
During the centuries that followed, disastrous epidemics would plague all humanity.
The most deadly spread across Europe in the 14th century.
Isis, fine silks, and beautiful precious stones direct from the Orient.
When we return to our Italy, we're going to be rich.
That's Caffa, a treasure trove of Italian merchandise.
We will take the city. Then we will be rich, you and I.
Yes, but you won't forget. We're going to share up.
I won't. Come on! Here's my hand on it.
So they won't resist for long.
We're sick, all turning black, blisters of fat, some can't move at all.
We'll go. Souvenir out in La City.
Death? Oh!
I have to get away!
Later, when the ship reached Italy, nearly everyone had died.
D'Avignon in France, the Pope...
...of deaths in Italy, in Britain, and in the northern kingdom of Denmark.
My son, faith is our only salvation. A pilgrimage to Rome, that is what is needed.
A million pilgrims on their way to Rome were to die.
Yes, there were terrible years. There were wars and famine, epidemics.
And what was the treatment?
Look, fever.
You have fever?
Fever.
That's right, enemas, bloodletting, purges.
The cure-alls they applied way back then.
But all that was to change with the coming of the Renaissance,
and they sought a better understanding of the human organism.
Leonardo da Vinci made accurate anatomical drawings.
Vesal published a remarkable work on anatomy
and tried to correct the mistakes that Gallien had made.
As always, there is public outcry and rejection.
And then appeared Ambrose Paré, an extraordinary man of destiny.
Ambrose, Ambrose, where are you?
Here I am.
Would you sweep the floor, please?
You see, must be cleaned up.
Yes, Father.
It's a bar.
Bleaches as usual.
And will that cure the patient?
Doctor thinks.
I would like to be a doctor.
My poor Ambrose.
You haven't an education.
You don't know Greek or Latin either.
You have to speak Latin to be able to cure?
You need them to name all the organs in the human body.
And all the illnesses. Oh, no, Ambrose, you will be a worker, a cook's helper.
I will?
Yes, why not? I've already found a job for you. It's settled.
But I want to be a doctor and cure people.
Yes, my boy, but you can't. Medicine's not a profession for the poor.
Where might I find Paul? Paul Paré?
That way, in the second ward on the left.
Suction cups, do you understand?
Yes, doctor, 12 suction cups.
Oh, Ambrose, my little brother, what are you doing here?
I thought you were working in a kitchen at Angers.
Uh-huh. I ran away. I don't want to be there. I want to be a doctor.
But you know that's not possible. You don't know any Greek or Latin.
Then I'll be a barber-surgeon, same as you.
Wait. I have to place my suction cups.
Yeah, you better do it, otherwise I'll get epistaxis. That's what the doctor said.
Just what is epistaxis?
It's a nosebleed. You see, if you don't know Latin, you can't be a doctor.
It seems to me I could cure a nosebleed without knowing what the Romans called it.
Epistaxis. Look, I'll manage, Paul.
Paul.
So, my lad, you want to be a barber-surgeon.
Good.
To begin with, you'll start as a nursing assistant, and then we'll see.
You see, when you empty an abscess, you make a quick cut in one movement.
An abscess, Ambrose, and you will open it.
And you will drain out all the pus otherwise.
It could poison the organism.
You've talent, Ambrose.
I award you the diploma of Master Barber-Surgeon.
Then what are you going to do now?
I volunteered to join the army of Marchand Marchand, who will be going to war in Piedmont, Professor Curtin.
I'll care for the wounded, and it will give me some more practical experience.
That's fine, lad. Good luck.
When you return, come and see me.
You know, the arquebus is an invention that's diabolical.
It makes terrible wounds.
And poisonous.
Eh, poisonous.
Very well, then we'll treat them with this. Boiling oil.
It causes great pain.
can't we find anything that's less cruel no nothing you'll let me die here like a rat i'll cure you
wait a minute what do you do to cure him there's no more oil and so i'll prepare a mixture we have
to save these people a mixture put in rose oil that's quite gentle i'll add turpentine as a
cleaning agent then i'll add an egg yolk an egg yolk yes it will thicken the mixture and it will
then be easier to apply and if it won't help let's wait and see for me it's not boiling oil
it just might is that why you up quickly let's go see the wounded it's inflamed it's the boiling
oil we'll take care of you you're the one i treated with my ointment your wound any better
now yes it doesn't hurt anymore you see you have to check on results do tests compare let's go find
some more eggs oil egg yolks turpentine we're ready what are you going to do clean the wounds
treated with boiling oil and then treat them in my own way.
But, hey, we don't have the right.
We always have the right to relieve suffering.
That's our job.
See, we're treating them, but in a more gentle and efficient way.
It can be more efficient than boiling oil.
The soldiers suffer needlessly in the treatment.
They're used to it.
These men are soldiers.
A joke.
There's also a little rose oil.
This is insubordination.
You will get put you in prison.
What's going on here?
These men are disobeying me.
I distinctly ordered...
And they treat wounds with boiling oil, and the wounded men will die.
Feeling not too bad, Captain.
Tomorrow I'll go back into combat.
You're responsible for this.
Yes, Captain, there was no more oil.
So I prepared an ointment that I devised and applied it.
Good work.
What's your name?
Ambrose Paré.
Well, Paré, you did just the right thing, and you're curing the men.
I treat them. God alone cures them.
I promote you to the rank of Chief Barber Surgeon of the Regiment.
Chief, sir? He disobeyed! He has to get punished!
You're demoted to assistant.
Now on you take orders from Ambrose Parade.
The soldier has an amputation.
Cauterize his wound with a hot eye. It's really inhuman.
Yes, but if we don't cauterize, he'll bleed to death.
Blood flows through vessels that are as big as that.
They could easily be sewn together.
Sewn together? You're joking, Ambrose.
No, in fact, I've already done it.
Such a thing to a man?
This dog's leg was blown away by a bomb.
I just cleaned out the stump and sewed up the wound.
Cauterize it?
Mm-mm.
We'll try a test.
It could work.
Good work, Doctor. My leg doesn't hurt me anymore.
I am not a doctor, my friend. No, I'm a barber-surgeon.
Oh, well, I'd say you're a better doctor than any doctor.
An idea. All right, stand up.
You think I...
Mm-hmm. Give me your crutches.
You sure about this?
Can't believe it. Is it true?
I'm walking by myself.
Oh, doctor, you've made a miracle.
It's a real miracle.
I'm going to show everybody.
Just a minute.
Sit down.
I have another idea.
Golly, it's the best yet.
Wonderful things about your work.
Would you like to return and work here?
Yes, Mr. Curtin.
There is so much I still want to learn.
Paré was soon equal to the greatest.
Pioneer in experimental medicine, accomplished surgeon.
He wanted to share his knowledge with everyone.
This is intolerable.
This barber.
This Ambrose Paré.
Now he's published a learned treatise.
And in French, not in Latin.
Next, any charlatan will come and claim to know our art.
It's an insult to our profession.
It's true.
It is a scandal.
He dares suggest that he can stitch up blood vessels.
We have been cauterizing for five centuries with success.
We must act.
That's right. Prosecure him.
And what was the result of all this uproar?
Ambrose.
King Henry has appointed you his surgeon.
You realize you're a lowly kitchen boy surgeon to the king?
Yes, Ambrose was soon famous, and he made many, many more discoveries.
Imagine, antiseptics before man even knew about microbes.
He was truly the father of modern medicine.
A few decades after Parry's death, another great doctor, Harvey, would discover the way blood circulates.
But as always, there were fools in the way of progress.
Gentlemen, the so-called bloodstream that Harvey says exists is ridiculous.
This is paradoxical, useless to medicine, wrong, impossible, unintelligent, absurd, and I'd even say harmful to humans.
The learned doctor you just heard saying that famous sentence is indeed Guy Patin,
who was none other than the dean of the Paris Faculty of Medicine at the time.
And there we have proof once more that it's never easy to be a discoverer.
*Muchas music*